en direct sur France 3 centre soyez les
bienvenus ici au domaine national de
chambor pendant près d'une heure on va
vous faire vivre le plus grand salon de
la chasse en France le Game fair ici au
pied d'un édifice l'un des plus ant la
vallée de la Loire bien évidemment le
château de chambor avec toutes les
équipes techniques et rédactionnelles on
va vous faire vivre cet événement
pendant une heure avec des invités des
surprises et j'ai la chance de présenter
cette émission avec den Gané meilleur
qui se trouve dans les allées du gamefir
cette 33e édition pour nous faire vivre
au cœur CE gamefire Denis bonjour
bonjour Benoît et je peux vous dire que
là je vous observe de près quand même
hein je suis en train de vous voir vous
êtes bien bien installé he merci et ben
oui on va vivre le GAM faire ensemble
pendant près d'une heure et je peux vous
dire déjà que dans les allées il y a du
monde par rapport à hier B c'est quand
même beaucoup plus agréable parce qu'il
fait moins lourd il fait moins chaud il
y a un petit vent frais il y a du monde
on parle pratiquement toutes les langues
c'est assez étonnant on vient de très
très loin même pour participer à ce game
fair alors bien entendu pour vous j'ai
préparer un certain nombre de surprise
vous vous en doutez Benoir
Denis merci Denis alors pour tout savoir
de cette 33e édition vous qui aimez la
chasse la faune la flore les chiens le
dressage vous êtes au bon endroit vous
êtes sur France 3 cent on se retrouve
sur ce plateau avec notre premierre
invité Alexandre figer c'est tout
simplement le direct du Game fair
bonjour Alexandre merci d'être avec nous
bonjour alors cette édition est-ce
qu'elle se passe bien c'est déjà la
deuxième journée pour vous tout le
boulot a été fait en amont est-ce que ça
se passe bien oui absolument tout se
passe bien on a la chance d'avoir la
météo avec nous et donc le public est au
rendez-vous une belle édition s'annonce
avec cette année la particularité
d'avoir ajusté un peu l'emplacement ce
n'est pas exactement comme l'empassé oui
le Game fair on a changé d'implantation
le Game fair pour avoir une un meilleur
confort de de d'accueil des visiteurs
des exposants on a essayé de faire un un
Game faire en mieux et qu'est-ce que
vous avez amélioré concrètement c'est
surtout l'accueil des visiteurs les
parkings sont plus proches par exemple
voilà plus de parking plus de les accès
plus faciles euh et des aller
redessiner un Game Fair qui permet de de
d'être sous un nouveau jour plus de
stand cette année encore on a 40 stand
en plus par rapport àniè donc on peut
accueillir plus de public plus
d'exposants et avec une multitude
d'animations donc un beau game fair ou
alors quelques chiffres le Game fair
c'est le plus grand salon de la chasse
en France on l'a dit 40 hectares sur les
5440 que compte le parc clos du domaine
sont consacrés pendant 3 jours au
gamefire 450 exposants qui viennent de
toute la France on va le voir et plus de
70000 visiteurs Alexandre c'est un peu
une ville entière qui vient s'installer
pendant 3 jours beaucoup de
responsabilité pour vous oui un gros
boulot c'est le fruit d' toute une
équipe qui est donc la rivière
organisation qui qui travaille sur le
projet depuis maintenant 7 8 mois donc
un gros travail de préparation et vous
êtes combien à travailler sur cet
événement on est tout un service bon
alors sur le moment on est peut-être on
est au environ 200 personnes euh on est
toute une équipe un service d'une
dizaine de personnes qui travaillent sur
l'événement euh un gros travail de
commercialisation de mise en place
technique 15000 m² de structure euh 40
hectares d'événements global donc il y a
un gros gros travail de mise en place
ouais c'est considérable et bien juste
on vous a suivi dans les Travis du
gamefir à la veille de l'ouverture
c'était jeudi pour voir votre quotidien
juste avant l'ouverture c'est un sujet
d'Amélie rigoanzo et de Pierre Dominique
Lopé NAD j'ai un souci d'un exposant
harcis qui a pas assez de place pour
installer son stand c'est un terrain nu
ce genre de problème Alexandre aura
probablement à en résoudre plus d'un à
la veille de l'ouverture ce petit
incident ne devrait pas enrayer la
grosse mécanique du Game fair avec le
Bol d'Or et le super cross de Paris
c'est l'une des plus grosses
manifestations que sa société
événementielle est à géré c'est 15000 m
car de structure c'est 150 personnes qui
travaillent 15 jours pour le
montage c'est une grosse grosse machine
ouais c'est la journée de montage il
faut vraiment que tout tout soit prêt
pour demain 10h30 l'ouverture donc donc
ouais il y a un compte àbour qui est
lancé faut faut que ça avance ou le
gamefir un salon dont la réputation a
largement franchi les portes de la
Sologne c'est pour cela que cet armurier
Chinonais a choisi d'y venir pour la
seconde année on commence à avir une
petite clientèle parisienne une petite
clientèle aussi du 41 du 45 86 il faut
évoluer avec 30 ans on peut pas rester
dans un petit coin de Ten en travaillant
disons en souterrain il faut quand même
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai mon fils qui
prend le relais derrière essayer
d'évoluer un peu et agrandir un petit
peu l'éventail des clients quoi d'autres
viennent de bien plus loin du plateau de
l'aurac je connaissais la réputation du
gamefire je suis actuellement enfin je
suis chasseur et c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de publicité dessus et cetera
donc j'ai souhaité faire le premier pas
cet artisan façonne les couteaux d'une
célèbre marque dont la fabrication
artisanale est mise à mal par la
contrefaçon le gamefire c'est l'espoir
de lui redonner tout son prestige moi je
vous dirait ça le dimanche soir voir
dans deux ou TR mois quand on aura les
premiers peut-être répercussion directe
sur le village le gamefir 33e édition 33
ans d'existence et devenu le plus grand
salon de chasse en
France Alexandre exposant partenaire
public finalement tout le monde a a ses
exigen oui tout à fait il faut répondre
à toutes les exigences des des exposants
euh et on est là pour ça et voilà c'est
ça fonctionne bien alors moi j'ai envie
de vous comparer un peu vous êtes un peu
à la chasse ce qui amoris Sport
Organisation au Tour de France non ouais
vous êtes content non ouais c'est la
concurrence allez merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous sur ce plateau et BC
courage le Game fair continue se
poursuit jusqu'à demain soir restez avec
nous merci beaucoup merci Alexandre
figer vous ê le directeur du Game fair
comme chaque année un pays est invité
pour participer au plus grand Salon de
la Chasse après le Qatar l'Écosse la
Biélorussie cette année c'est le Burkina
Faso qui est l'invité d'honneur le
Burkina petit pays d'Afrique francophone
occidentale présentation Rebecca
benborek le pays des hommes intègres
c'est la traduction littérale de
BurkinaFaso un pays de 16 millions
d'habitants au cœur de l'Afrique de
l'Ouest le sud du Burkina Faso est riche
de vastes territoires sauvages là-bas il
y a cet endroit le célèbre ranch de
Nazinga une réserve naturelle où les
stars sont les éléphants on en dénomce
nbre plus de
600 des troupeaux d'antilopees
traversent parfois les routes il y a
aussi des buffles et puis des babouin
qui courent et grimpe un peu
partout parmi les reptiles des
crocodiles dans la savane le petit
gibier est aussi très présent les
facochè côtoient les antilopes naines et
toutes sortes d'oiseaux la faune
burkinabé est reconnu comme exceptionnel
et varié malgré ses richesses le
tourisme est encore très peu développé
au Burk FO un pays qui conserve
néanmoins toute son
authenticité alors avant d'en parler
avec le ministre de l'Environnement et
du Développement durable du Burkina on
va tout de suite retrouver Denis qui est
au stand du Burkina Faso au fin fond du
gamefir ah oui c'est la magie et je suis
au Burkina Faso fort comme un lion bien
entendu oui bon et alors dans ce village
et bien vous pouvez tout découvrir he
sur le le Burkina Burkina Faso qui veut
dire littéralement le pays des hommes
intègres et là je vais aller rejoindre
mon invité c'est Pierre bonjour Pierre
comment ça va bonjour bonjour je vais a
vous ben très bien merci alors on va
parler parce que vous êtes le
spécialiste quand même hein de de la
chasse dans ce P directeur de la Fée des
chasses de Burkina Faso voilà et donc on
va parler de de de chasse en général de
grands gibiers de petits gibiers
qu'est-ce que l'on pourrait dire d'abord
que ce pays a la chance d'avoir un peu
tous les paysage de l'Afrique on va y
retrouver une terre un peu sèche au nord
et une terre beaucoup plus luxoriante au
sud en effet le le Burkina Faso est
situé au cœur de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
et sa position géographique fait de lui
un pays avec différents écosystèmes don
des écosystème sahélien et un peu souano
sahélien si bien que au nord on a
euh le Sahel avec souvent des dunes de
sable mais aussi des mares et grande Mar
donc on peut on on peut pêcher on peut à
la fois pêcher on peut à la fois chasser
du petit gibier et du grand gibier oui
là au Sael il y a bien sûr la la pêche
la pêche avec avec les populations local
mais aussi la chasse aux oiseaux d'eau
surtout des espèces migratrices du
piatique occidental mais également des
espèces
locales africaines comme les gangas on
fait des pass
voà voilà alors sur on va il y a bien
une grande différence on va marcher un
petit peu pierre tous les deux parce
qu'on va découvrir vous avez installé au
cœur de ce village où on peut découvrir
tous les safaris possibles hein c'est ça
qui est absolument génial alors vous
avez organisé un stand qui représente on
va s'en approcher ensemble qui
représente et bien sur le grand gibier
en tout cas qui représente ce que l'on
peut chasser au Burkina en effet vous
avez au niveau de ce stand une un peu
une représentation de quelques espèces
c'est un échantillon des espèces de
grande chasse au Burkina et l'espèce
phare ou les espac les espèces phares
que que vous avez il y a le bufle il y a
le il y a le lion mais également le Coba
ou l'hyppotrag l'antilope cheval qui est
quand même une espèce emblématique alors
et et puis il y en a un on va marcher je
sais pas si on aura le temps de le voir
et al on va aller voir les les musiciens
parce qu'il y a plein de musiciens sur
votre stand he c'est très bienis on a
deux groupes qui nous accompagnent
durant ces 3 jours de présence au salon
et on est à côté de du groupe de dozo le
dozo qui est une confrerie de chasseurs
traditionnels au Burkina et qui ont leur
danse à eux et quand vous n'êtes pas
initié vous pouvez pas être être de
groupe et on a également des artistes du
Centre national de l'art euh de
l'art du burkinaou qui organise qui qui
qui fédère un peu la culture nationale
donc qui fait des part de toutes les du
Burkina oui merci Pierre vous avez bien
parlé de de votre pays je vous invite à
venir voir ce stand et et dites-moi
Benoît vous êtes avec le le bah le
patron de la chasse vous hein oui qui
n'est autre que le ministre de
l'Environnement et du Développement
durable il s'agit de Sifou draugo merci
d'être avec nous bonjour bonjour c'est
une joie pour vous d'être ici à
Chambourg d'avoir été invité ici mais
oui c'est un honneur parce que être
invité d'honneur ce grand salon c'est ça
permet au Burkina Faso de présenter ses
potentialités en matière de Faun en
matière de tourisme donc nous sommes
vraiment très reconnaissants et très
contents d'être parmi les gens de la
région pour présenter nos vra
possibilités en ma qu'est-ce qui vous
inspire ces lieux ah mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est la merveil c'est joli nous
voyons que il y a une symbiose entre la
nature et que euh euh le monde de la
chasse est représenté à tous les niveaux
c'est un moment pour nous privilégier à
partir duquel nous allons tirer des
expériences pour aller de l'avant en
matière de gestion de notre ressources
fournir alors on va parler de la chasse
au Burkina un territoire rich et varié
on l'a vu avec Denis euh quels sont les
espèces protégées qui sont interdites à
la
chasse l'espèce inter c'est l'éléphant
la chasse à l'éléphant l'hippopotame
principalement et puis le porque épique
et un peu l'éléphant et le lion parce
que bon il on tue le Lyon mais il y a
quand même une restriction en matière
d'exploitation de liyon mais les les
principales espèces les plus protégées
c'est surtout l'éléphant et
l'hippopotame quelle est la politique
que vous menez pour trouver l'équilibre
entre la chasse une chasse touristique
faut pas se se cacher la vérité et la la
protection des espèces comment vous
arrivez à à faire en sorte que tout cela
fonctionne nous avons essayer de créer
un partenariat entre l'État le secteur
privé et les communautés à la base
l'État ça pour créer un environnement
plus ou moins propice à l'exploitation
rationnelle des ressources naturelles
phoniques et aussi le secteur privé
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que
l'État seul ne peut pas et que avec le
nombre d'espaces des des protégés que
nous avons d'air protégés de forêt
classiqu que nous avons nous avons des
concessionnaires privés à qui nous avons
donc confié ces espaces donc pour gérer
de manière rationnelle donc ces
concessions dé charg et enfin les
communautés à la base parce que il faut
que de manière plus ou moins efficiente
et rationnelle la gestion de ces
ressources phoniques à profite
communauté à la base donc c'est c'est
c'est ce sont ces trois partenaires qui
sont les fondements de notre politique
en matière de gestion phonique pour
lutter contre un fléo le braconnage on
peut on peut le dire ex enc FL c'est un
fléo national surrégional international
parce que nos éléphants sont braconnés
et l'ivoire est devenu vraiment une
source de revenu pour des des des des
des grands braconniers parce que le
kilogam d'Ivoire coûteant 300000 francs
CFA et nous faisons face vraiment à
beaucoup de braconnage c'est le c'est le
point noir en matière de gestion de la
forêt et de la faune chez nous combien y
y a-t-il de de chasseurs européens qui
qui viennent chaque année au bin Fasso
en moyenne nous avons une moyenne
annuelle de 1600 touristes chasseurs
sportifs et parmi ces 1600 il y a
environ 650 à 700 européens dont les
plus importants 80 % ce sont les
Français après les Américains les Russes
et les Canadiens voilà merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre d'avoir été avec
nous sur ce plateau et profitez bien du
gamefer et et de la région du loirelcher
et de la Sologne merci beaucoup merci
merci on va parler d'une autre chasse
exceptionnelle elle a lieu chaque année
ici même dans le parc clos du domaine
national de chambor c'est le maire André
jolie qui l'organise on appelle ça la
chasse communale et vous allez le voir
le gibier est en abondance sanglier
chevreuil serre le spectacle est à la
hauteur du site les images sont signées
pierredinique
Lopé il est 9h les 32 fusils sont postés
les chiens autant excités que leur
maîtres non non non
tiens la chasse communale de chambor
réservé au habitants vient tout juste de
débuter dérangé ce ser et ses biches
n'ont pas à s'inquiéter seul les
sangliers seront au tableau ce
soir après quelques minutes de trac le
spectacle est déjà exceptionnel il faut
dire que la réserve naturelle offre une
diversité et un concentré de gibier
unique en
Europe nous en habitant de la commune ça
nous fait le l'occasion de chasser dans
le dans le parc une fois dans l'année
puis c'est quand même un niveau quand
même assez élevé c'est quand même une
belle chasse
Chambord et beaucoup de monde voudrait
venir à Chambord et nous on a la chance
de pouvoir y aller une fois dans l'année
donc c'est c'est un petit peu la fête
quoi pour nous à chambor après les batus
du matin les chasseurs sont invités à
prendre un ANCA au Pavillon ce jour-là
parmi les invités du maire des
chambourdins bien sûr mais aussi
quelques notables du coin ici ni patron
du CAC 40 ni homme politique parisien la
chasse communale est la plus populaire
des chasses de
régulation on organise exactement de la
même façon et on essaie de gérer au
mieux la journée pour que tout se passe
bien il est important qu'elle se
perpétue cette tradition pour la la
chasse la chasse communale bah bien sûr
ça fait partie de d'une tradition et il
faut que les les gens du village
puissent chasser au moins une fois par
an comme les ouvriers forestier chasse
une fois par an aussi si les chasses
présidentielles ont bien été supprimées
sous l'air Sarkozi les chasses de
régulation subsistent et pour cause les
bonnes années quand la nourriture est
abondante une population de sangliers
peut doubler alors pour préserver
l'équilibre du Biotop il est nécessaire
d'en prélever la
moitié
la nuit est tombée sur chambor l'heure
de rendre les derniers honneurs au
sangliers tombés dans la
journée au cours de cette journée vos
invités ont tiré 281 coups de feu et
prélevé 94
sanglier botte noire redingotte et bombe
sur la tête les sonneurs font retentir
leur trompe dans le ciel étoilé du
domaine et nous sommes de retour sur ce
plateau pour vous faire vivre cette 33e
édition du Game fair et vous voyez il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de monde voilà
coucou bonjour à tous beaucoup de monde
ici à chambor pour le plus grand Salon
de la Chasse et je reçoit à présent sur
ce plateau quelqu'un que nous
connaissons bien à France 3 centre
Hubert Louis buitton vous êtes le
président de la fédération de chasse de
la région Centre mais aussi du Loir
etcher bonjour du département exactement
c'est un moment fort pour vous également
le le gamefire je suppose mais c'est
évident pour nous un moment
indispensable étant donné que c'est un
lieu d'échange un lieu de rencontre nous
sommes contents de rencontrer nos
adhérents les adhérents de d'autres
départements et surtout les non
chasseurs qui viennent à notre rencontre
et on est content de les renseigner sur
notre pbion il y en a beaucoup des non
chasseurs qui viennent au gamefer c'est
pas exclusivement réservé au chasseurs
il y a une grosse partie quand même des
des gens des curieux c'est normal donc
avec déjà un cadre comme Chambord on
vient à Chambord et donc quand ils
voient le mot chasseur ils sont quand
même à la rencontre de nous ils viennent
nous voir alors à l'origine le gamefir
ça avait été créé pour préparer la
saison de chasse suivante c'est un peu
toujours le cas mais c'est surtout une
grande fête aujourd'hui voilà avant
c'était fait pour les chasseurs ça c'est
sûr ils venaient aménager leur
territoire acheter les miradeur tout ce
qu'il faut pour une saison de chasse
future donc voilà mais maintenant ça
s'est démocratisé ça s'est ouvert à tout
le monde et c'est très bien parce que la
chasse doit s'ouvrir à tout le monde et
on est les premiers à recevoir tout le
monde comment vous faire comment vous
faites pour faire naître des vocations
là c'est très difficile c'est de plus en
plus dur parce que la vocation de
chasseur se fait surtout dans les états
de famille le père le grand-père on
accueille les enfants donc on est
heureux de de de participer de une
journée de chasse en famille que ça soit
du Grand ou du petit gibier donc voilà
le la difficulté c'est par la famille
donc bah quand toute la famille est
présente tout va bien c'est là où un
petit peu de temps en temps alors on va
faire le point justement sur l'état de
la chasse en région Centre avec
Sébastien Nissand et Jean-Pierre brussau
la Sologne un paradis pour le gibier un
vaste terrain de jeu pour les chasseurs
de la région mais pas seulement ce
matin-là c'est un groupe d'amis venu de
Mosel qui commence sa journée dans l'une
des nombreuses chasses privées de la
forêt histoire de se faire plaisir et de
découvrir un milieu complètement
différent de ce qu'il a l'habitude de
voir ça démarre très très bien on a déjà
fait quelques pièces on est chasseur
Laurin chasse plutôt le grand gibier
mais on vient chez nos amis de Sologne
pour pouvoir s'adapt un peu au petit
gibier ici ils ont gardé ils ont gardé
la nature ils ont gardé la chasse comme
avant on chasse encore dans le sous-bois
et et c'est des chasseurs ici c'est des
très très beaux animaux c'est ce qu'on
vient rechercher rechercher de beaux
animaux mais aussi de la convivialité
c'est ainsi que le chasseur attise sa
gourmandise de chasse en sol
on va répartir deux fusils qui vont
partir avec John à pied une chasse très
varié qui vont venir avec moi en camion
donc les armes sous étu pouront monter
dans dans le véhicule chevreuil ser
sanglier ou encore gibier d'eau comme
ici autour de l'un des 3000 étant
solonneau de quoi bien remplir le
tableau de chasse ainsi que le tiroir
caisse c'est une journée qui équilibre
les budgets les chasses de groupe c'est
des chasses importantes parce que c'est
elle qui
génère le plus en terme de bénéfice mais
c'est une un ensemble sur l'année avec
des journées avec plutôt des individuels
et des jours souvent les weekends où
c'est plutôt des chasses de groupes qui
qui prime avec des plus de monde sur les
terrains malgré la crise le centre reste
l'un des territoires français où la
chasse est prépondérante ces dernières
années le nombre de chasseurs a même
augmenté il est passé de 91500 adhérents
en 2011 à plus de 100000 aujourd'hui
réparti sur les six fédérations que
compte la région Huber Louis Vuitton il
a légèrement augmenté mais l'érosion est
quand même globalement il y a une
érosion depuis 20 30 ans en France et en
région Centre oui malheureusement on
baisse le nombre de chasseurs baissent
tous les ans bon on essaie de maintenir
on essaie de faire le maximum pour
essayer de retenir nos chasseurs de
faire découvrir d'avoir des nouveaux
chasseurs mais le coût de la vie est là
ça devient de plus en plus difficile
donc qu'est-ce qui explique ce ce
chiffre en constante baisse c'est aussi
le le prix peut-être de la la pratique
de ce sport loisir malheureusement je
suis d'accord je pense que le cûp est là
la vie de la le coût de la vie est
beaucoup trop cher la chasse est cher
nous avons de gros problèmes c'est au
niveau des des dégâts agricoles où donc
on est obligé de payer aux agriculteur
le les dégâts agricoles donc c'est des
taxes supplémentaires donc un jeune
chasseur qui arrive dans une chasse est
obligé de participer au frais donc voilà
donc on peut rentrer un peu dans les
chiffres passer son permis aujourd'hui
c'est une cinquantaine d'euros par
contre passer une journée en Sologne
quand on est jeune chasseur c'est 250 €
la journée oui il y a tout tarif ça
dépend si on va chasser grand ou petit
gibier voilà il y a tout tarif ça dépend
de la qualité de la chasse mais voilà
oui il y a un coup je disais 250 €
minimum minimum c'est cher oui c'est
très cher c'est trop cher pour un jeune
faut faire quelque chose surtout dans
les conditions actuelles et ça va de
tout ça va de l'équipement de du chien
de l'action de chasse voilà du transport
voilà on pense à des cartouches il faut
penser à tout donc voilà voilà le cûp
est là avant tout alors vous vous
cherchez à recruter des chasseurs il y a
aussi besoin de de chasseresse un peu
plus encore que contrairement aux hommes
elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses à
s'inscrire et à pratiquer cette
discipline exemple dans le Limousin
sujet signé Florient rouliè et Frédéric
bord à chaque ouverture la même
impatience les chiens à peine lâchés
difficile de les
contrôler moi mon rôle aujourd'hui c'est
de faire suivre les véhicules avec les
chiens de lâcher les chiens ben au
moment où les animaux ont été cernés si
char n'a pas de fusil son rôle est
essentiel dans cette batue au sanglier
avec elle deux autres chasseresses des
Dianes comme on les appelle dans le
milieu aujourd'hui 10 % des chasseurs
sont des femmes Emeline est l'une d'elle
elle chasse depuis 8 ans à l'époque
c'était presque une
exception autrefois en fait on avait à
peu près 2 % de femmes et à peu près 10
ans donc et cette augmentation
essentiellement du au fait que les
femmes ont souvent
accompagné leur maris leurs copains à la
chasse et que aujourd'hui elle passe le
cap et ell elles veulent devenir
chasseur comme comme leur mari ou leur
copains une activité qui attire même les
plus jeunes sur les territoires les plus
ruraux la chasse et dans les gênes de
père en fils ou plutôt de père en
fille si je crois qu'il a deux endroits
où où il y a des des ou à 16 ans coralie
est en train de passer son permis de
chasse aujourd'hui elle dresse
d'ailleurs la petite chienne qui la
suivra les saisons prochaines pour
s'entraîner elle a fait le choix de
pratiquer la chasse à compag
je suis mon père avec une arme une arme
pour deux et donc mon père me parinene
et puis je si je peux essayer de
m'entraîner je vais tirer sur sur le JBI
d'ici quelques jours Coralie pourra
chasser toute seule si tout va bien
l'association de chasse se féminisera
alors encore un peu plus pas sûr que le
gibier fasse la différence alors Hubert
Louis Vitton elles en avaient marre
d'attendre leur mari à la maison les
femmes ça c'est le grand truc non non
mais bon le monde de la chasse s ouvert
une fois de plus doublement aux femmes
et on est très heureux quand dans une
équipe de de chasse il y a des femmes
donc non non non et elles ne viennent
pas que pour faire la cuisine non plus
on les accueille au poste et pourra
faire une action de chasse elles sont
elles ont un bon coup de fusil ou pas
rapidement ah il y en a oui oui je suis
très surpris j'ai je me suis déjà rendu
compte ettre voisin au poste avec des
femmes et ne pas avoir le temps de lever
la carabine et celles qui ont prélevé le
jbiet donc c'est bien merci beaucoup
Huber Louis buitton si vous êtes chez
vous vous pouvez aussi aller sur notre
site internet c. 3.fr préparé par
Delphine crro et Laurence agatenzi
dossier complet bien sûr sur ce 33e game
fair allez on va retrouver une autre
femme qui n'aura pas un fusil entre ses
mains demain à 11h mais un coup de
marteau Denis il s'agit de marieedit
pouscnet et bien oui bien sûr c'est
Marie edit qui est à côté de moi bonjour
Marie edit que de monde que de monde sur
votre stand en effet je suis très très
heureuse et satisfaite de cette réunion
au gamefire où il y a énormément de
monde une foule depuis vendredi et nous
ferons donc la vente aux enchères demain
matin c'est noté demain matin laavant au
enchères bon en dehors des armes
marieedit on envoit bon il y a beaucoup
de choses comme ça en dehors des armes
en dehors des trophées hein ce qu'on met
dans les salons avec les bois et bien il
y a l'art c'est toujours intéressé à la
chasse et vice-versa bien sûr ici nous
sommes à Sambor dans le domaine de la
chasse mais aussi dans le domaine de
l'art puisque les rois de France
venaient et aiment les arts
donc ici nous avons une représentation
que ce soit de gravure de sculpture
d'animaux naturalisés de couteau de
chasse et divers objets de tapisserie
aussi qui servaient dans le domaine des
châteaux pour protéger contre le froid
merci Marie je vais aller rejoindre
Guillaume c'est votre fils parce que
justement vous avez parlé de d'animaux
qui ont été empaillés on va aller voir
un un lion tout à fait c'est pas un lion
c'est un tigre tout à fait
extraordinaire alors bien entendu je
rappelle c'est une antiquité hein c'est
ça date d' un certain nombre d'années
comment ça va Guillaume très bien très
bien 2è jour d'exposition ça va va le
coup ça va ça va aller ça va aller
demain matin 10hou coup de marteau alors
là j'ai bien précisé que c'est une
antiquité c'est une antiquité c'est un
tigre naturalisé qui a été chassé en
Afrique au début du 20e siècle qui a été
naturalisé par la suite par en Belgique
il a été ensuite vendu à un grand
collectionneur belge qui nous le confie
à la vente aujourd'hui pour le gamefire
VO alors si vous voulez l'avoir dans
votre prix de départ pour leavoir dans
son salon fa compter 5000 € ah oui quand
même alors on va regarder une dernière
chose maintenant qui est une rareté
c'est alors c'est cette sculpture oh
c'est mignon parce que regardez c'est un
chien il a mal à sa patte il a un
pansement à sa patte il se gratte un
petit peu voyez-vous c'est ça c'est ça
exactement il a son pansement il est en
train de se lécher son pansement ce
pauvre chien qui a sûrement pris pr un
coup à la chasse c'est un plâtre
d'Emmanuel fremier qui est un un
sculpteur animalier du 19e et on a un
modèle quasi identique qui est conservé
au musée d'ors en bronze très bien merci
Guillaume bon alors je vais faire
quelques achats enfin on verra demain
matin pour le coup de marteau c'est à
quelle heure c'est 11h 11h pour le coup
de marteau demain matin vous avez votre
carte bleue je vais regarder bon déjà si
vous avez de quoi m'offrir un verre tout
à l'heure avec plaisir allez on va vous
retrouver dans quelques instants dans un
stand un peu plus surprenant pour parler
de trophée de chasse des anomalies mais
avant cela on va continuer de parler de
trophée de ser certains sont ENF chaque
fin d'hiver ils sont répertoriés classés
présentés dans chaque fédération
départementale de France exemple dans le
Loir etcher à quelques kilomètres de
chambor c'était à duison avec Xavier
nezé et Jean-Pierre brussau il y en a en
tout 640 voici réunis dans cette salle
la totalité desess a battu cette saison
en Loire et Cher plus deux spécimenses
morts au combat pendant le Bram
l'occasion pour les chasseurs de poser
fièrement devant leur
trophée c'est le premier ser que je tire
en plus le premier ser de que je tire de
ma vie donc j'ai eu la chance de le
prélever donc c'estou je suis assez
content c'est une belle réussite c'est
beaucoup de chance surtout quoi celui-ci
a été abattu au nord du département dans
la forêt de marchennoir mais c'est bien
sûr en Sologne que se trouvent les
populations les plus importantes le plus
beau trophée de l'année que voici ici à
droite a été prélevé à la Ferté un beau
chaque spécimen fait l'objet d'une
cotation en fonction de critèr bien
précis on va prendre le diamètre de la
meule qui elle en fonction de l'âge va
grossir hein puisque'à chaque fois que
le bois va tomber il va repousser mais
la meule va prendre un petit peu de de
diamètre ensuite on prendra une
dimension au-dessus du surendouiller une
deuxème dimension au-dessus de la
chevillure ou de la trochure le nombre
de pointes au total et surtout son poids
en établissant cette cotation la
fédération ne cherche pas à créer une
compétition il s'agit plutôt d'analyser
l'évolution du gibier dans le
département les populations de ser
augmentent mais elle restent
qualitativement trop jeune près de 80 %
des animaux abattus au moins de 4 ans il
faut donc inciter les tireurs à ne pas
appuyer trop tôt sur la gâchette notre
pyramide des âges est pas si mal que ça
puisqu'on a des bons exemples avec les
seres côtés qui représentent 23 % des
seres donc les seres qui rentrent en
cotation donc c'est des seres qui ont
des données biométriques intéressante et
souvent c'est des vieux seres donc si on
demande aux gens de de de pas prélever
entre guillemets n'importe quoi c'est
pour les laisser vieillir et pour que
les les ses atteignent un âge de plus de
10 ans et là sont complètement épanouis
au niveau du Trophée la saison passée
confirme la tendance le loircher reste
parmi les trois départements où on
trouve le plus de ser en France et le
centre est la région la plus plus peuplé
oui la Sologne particulièrement on va
tout de suite vous voyez y a toujours
autant de monde he qui est venu cet
après-midi pour ce game fair c'est un
vrai succès populaire on va retrouver
tout de suite Denis à nouveau dans les
stands ils sont chez nos amis québécois
alors ils étaient déjà invités l'an
dernier mais ça s'est tellement bien
passé et ben que la direction du gamefir
les a réinvité ben oui absolument et là
là vous voyez là je je viens avec mon
char parce que au Québec on dit un un
char bonjour La Belle Province comment
ça va oh j'ai ma petite marieclaude je
coupe le moteur he ma petite marieclaude
qui est là comment ça va marieclaude on
disait la Belle Province c'est c'est un
grand très grand pays de chasse
exactement nous on est au Québec on est
une des plus grandes pouvoiries en
Amérique du Nord de chasse et pêche 260
km²r de territoire à découvrir pour on
pêche la chasse aussi les vacances alors
justement j'aimerais avoir une petite
précision c'est sur pourvoirie que c'est
quoi exactement viens avec moi parce
qu'on vaer on va aller voir quelque
chose oui la pvoirie c'est de
l'ébergement en forêt puis on aussi on
peut pêcher et chasser alors c'est
l'hébergement en forêt c'est un peu bon
allez je vais la faire c'est un peu la
petite cabane au Canada et voilà c'est
de l'hébergement de luxe ou de la cabane
la cabane au Canada alors là je voudrais
qu'on voit un un ours il y a un ours qui
est là pardon excusez-moi messieur dames
on va pas voir l'ours on est en direct
sur France 3 excusez-moi si vous voulez
vous déplacer voilà on on va voir cette
ours alors il faut préciser il faut
préciser que c'est pas comme chez chez
nous en France hein ù voilà c'est très
réglementé chez vous la la chasse à
l'ours c'est Couron oui on fait la
chasse à l'ours il y a des il y a au
printemps puis aussi à l'automne sur
certains territoire qu'on peut faire la
chasse à l'os à l'automne donc on l'a on
a on obtient des permis puis c'est
possible d'avoir d'aller dans une
pourvoiri et et de faire la chasse à
l'ourse vous avez remarqué elle a les
mêmes yeux que le drapeau du
Québec bon je vais voir Nicolas il est
où mon Nicolas là où il a l'air occupé
pardon excusez-moi messieurs dames voilà
il est où mon Nicolas Nicolas Nicolas me
voilà alors lui Nicolas il venait j'ai
j'ai j'ai des choses on est en direct
sur France 3 Comment ça va sur je vais
vous demander monsieur de vous déplacer
c'est g très aimable à vous parce que je
vais vous demander une chose on va
parler de la pêche avec lui parce que on
a parlé bien entendu de de de la chasse
de la chasse à alors il me fait croire
depuis de jours que je connais que c'est
pas lui qui est sur la photo regardez
mettez-vous à côté Nicolas regardez non
regardez regardez regardez
hop vous êtes pêcheur non non moi je su
pas pêcheur j'ai pas le droit de dire
c'est moi parce que les gens sa que des
fois je suis en vacances c'est pas moi
c'est vraiment pas moi je veux juste
vous dire que c'est pas moi c'est le
vrai bonheur là-bas la pêche là-bas
c'est tout aussi important que la chasse
et puis on en a fait même on en a vu
dans des films des choses comme ça on
s'est beaucoup intéressé à la pêche il y
a du grand poisson il y a du petit
poisson il y a de tout là-bas oui il y a
des tout nous on a des som de comme ça
on a du brochet on a des Gard on a tout
sorte de poisson super agréable à pêcher
il y a aussi que la pêche ça peut être
une vacance aussi on peut ne pas pêcher
à la pêche et rien faire ça qui quand
même très bien aussi sais quand il fait
beau soleil on ouvre une petite une
petite consommation on relaxe sur le
barord de l'eau c'est bien ça vous avez
vu comment il faut la la promotion de la
Belle Province la Belle Province oh là
là non non la Belle Province VO là je
vais être mal là tout à l'heure bon
alors merci Nicolas merci Nicolas vous
êtes plusieurs hein on va dire plusieurs
sur avoir fait Prati une allée complète
surbecbec ou c'est super bien
ouais on est t ici tous les tous les bon
pour voyur sont ici ça so aujourd'hui
merci Nicolas je vous dis au revoir au
revoir au revoir la Belle Province je
l'ai bien dit cette fois-ci alle j'ai
peur allez on y on va les rejoindre oui
je vous entends je vous entends je vous
ai prévu un petit peu de sport là
allez-y allez-y là courz un petit peu là
ah oui ah oui oh là là mon Dieu faire un
peu de sport voilà je fais courir tout
le monde on va aller on va aller à un
endroit je vais vous raconter avec des
têtes bizardes alors bizardes j'ai hâte
de voir ça j'attends oui mais oui les
les têtes bizardes en en français mais
très ancien B bizard c'était le féminin
bizarre et euh en en matière de de bois
de serre chez le cvidé on dit bizarde
aussi parce que et bien c'est un terme
qui est resté alors vous voyez dans les
allées il y a beaucoup de monde et je
vais aller voir un monsieur qui est pas
comme les autres qui s'appelle le
docteur euh Alain François que que je
vais venir chercher al il très pris hein
c'est un spécialiste venez voir hop là
pardon excusez-moi docteur docteur je
vais cherger le docteur excusez-moi
monsieur je ben on est en direct j'avais
dit que je viendrais vous voir ça va
voilà le
doctur le docteur Alain François euh
vous avez une exposition tout à fait
originale merci merci tout à fait je
crois que c'est la première fois qu'on
arrive à faire un an de travail qu'on
arrive à présenter autant de choses sur
le sanglier bon vous allez me me suivre
on va passer de de l'autre côté parce
qu'on va on va regarder quelques de
trois petites particularités alors
bougez pas pardon messieurs dames ah oui
il est comme ça je passe n'importe où
j'emmène le docteur avec moi alors je
précise je précise qu'il est radiologue
c'est d'où vous êtes venu cette passion
c'est parce que vous étiez radiologue
vous avez mis la chasse j'ai bien les
choses un peu bizarres et j'ai puis en
plus ça je suis un collectionneur de
plein de choses ouais alors euh très
étrange quand même hein ça fait ça faut
un peu les jetons quand même hein
regardez alors qu'est-ce qui lu est
arrivé à lui alors celui-là il a eu une
blessure très jeune h h il a une
particularité bon ça il a le bout du nez
qui est à moitié parti mais il a ce
qu'il a c'est que il a gardé comme il
était jeune il il y a eu la croissance
qui s'est fait sur le reste du corps et
il a gardé la taille du groin du bout du
groin de d'origine donc il a un petit gr
un grin qui ne va pas du tout avec le
reste de la tête alors c'est assez
extraordinaire venez venez avec moi
docteur il celui-là je me le garde
pourant dans dans alors non on et et
celui-là vient d'arriver parce qu'on on
lui en apporte alors je voulais préciser
une petite chose c'est parce que voilà
ça alors ça c'est une tête assez
particulière parce que c'est congénital
c'est ça exactement exactement c'est une
asymétrie de développement du massif
nasal ouais ah oui alors voilà alors je
vais vous expliquer venez sur ce stand
c'est formidable vous verrez des choses
tout à fait étonnantes alors quand il
m'a regardé hier il m'a dit vous avez un
truc de chevreuil je comprenais rien du
tout j'ai apparemment un truc de
chevreuil expliquez rapidement le truc
de Chev c'est le syndrome de la Mèche
Blanche vous voyez regardez il est gris
comme ça mais il a une petite mèche
blanche ici comme ça et ça'appelle le
piedvaldisme oui ensuite il y a le nez
après je vous êtes un boxeur il dit pas
du tout il me dit c'est naissance ah bah
je dis vous êtes comme celui là donc ça
c'est une campiloniatie voilà voil donc
moi je je crois que je vais pas rester
trop longtemps parce que
pense je vais finir sur un mur oui un
tableau de chasse je finir sur un mur
merci merci merci Denis merci à votre
invité on se retrouve sur ce plateau
avec deux invités deux sportifs j'ai à
mes côtés Didier Navaro bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes champion de
jky on va y revenir avec vous à vos côté
Dominique Bado ancien cycliste bonjour
bonjour vous êtes du coin vous ou ouais
moi je suis laabine donc le pays le pays
de chasse juste à côté alors tous les
deux on va commencer par Didier vous
êtes tombé un peu dedans quand vous
étiez petit hein la chasse complètement
à l'âge à l'âge de 5 6 ans j'ai baigné
dans un environnement familial qui était
très proche de la chasse donc ça m'a
donné le goût de la chasse de la nature
et derrière tout ça après j'ai passé le
permis et et maintenant je peux arriver
à souvir ma passion avec votre accent là
vous venez d'où là je viens du gare d'un
petit village qui s'appelle
saint-maximain à côté de du ZES et bien
justement je vais vous présenter un
petit peu vous êtes six fois champion du
monde et SEP fois champion d'Europe de
jet ski on va le voir sur ces images
vous avez tout gagné hein au début des
années 90 et au à la fin des années 90
années 2000 et vous avez été l'un des
premiers à dominer les Américains dans
une discipline c'est un peu une fierté
ça non
ouais bien sûr c'est une fierté moi je
suis très très Chauvin c'est vrai que ça
m'a fait plaisir de pouvoir être le
premier Européen à battre des pilotes
professionnels américains je pense que
derrière ça a ouvert derrière beaucoup
de d'ouverture ça a été une ouverture
pour tous les pilotes français européens
et dans d'autres disciplines le BMX
ouais bien évidemment comme Jean-Michel
B l'a pu le faire en motocross par
exemple et aujourd'hui et bien on en est
que la la France est et leader du au
niveau mondial on va revenir à à la
chasse comment vous avez fait pour
concilier sport de haut niveau et chasse
ça a été ça a été très difficile en tout
cas pendant pendant 15 ans 20 ans si
vous voulez mais les dernières années de
de ma carrière j'ai pu prendre un peu
plus de temps et m'y remettre je partage
ça maintenant à fond avec mon fils et je
peux pleinement aujourd'hui chasser en
ayant un peu plus de temps et vous
Dominique vous avez fait comment pour
concilier les deux avec le cyclisme ah
ça c'est un petit peu sur le même
principe que Didier moi j'ai la Braine
étant le le pendant de la selogne on
baigne on est on tombe dans la marmite
petit hein ça c'est logique on peut pas
faire un pays plus cynégétique que
laabine aussi donc cyclisme forcément
c'était des saisons intéressantes parce
que le cyclisme s'arrêté à peu près fin
septembre la chasse débuté c'est vrai
que c'était assez facile bon il y avait
une petite transition
Dené alors vous êtes arrivé tous les
deux hier et justement comme chaque
année des sportifs sont invités des
sportifs chasseurs il y a David douiller
Luc alfan ou encore le boxeur local
Bruno girer qui a été champion du monde
reportage Amélie ranzo avec Pierre
Dominique
leopé à eux tous ils ont 43 titres de
champion ou vice-champion du monde c
titres olympiques et 52 de champion de
France tout au long de leur carrière ces
grands noms du sport français ont trouvé
dans la chasse un moyen d'évacuer la
pression des compétitions la chasse
c'est un sport et ça permet d'oublier
tout c'est c'est on oublie tous les
soucis c'est une question de se balader
avec ses chiens j'ai de la Bras d'Or
donc ça permet de'oublier on se vide la
tête créé dans les années 2000
l'association des sportifs chasseurs a
pour objectif de véhiculer une image
respectueuse de la chasse le capitaine
de l'équipe de rugby de Brive vient tout
juste de rejoindre le groupe dans l'état
d'esprit de se retrouver ensemble le
matin nous on se retrouve ensemble avant
les matchs après de de de peut-être une
équipe pour pour sortir le gibier du
bois et ben nous c'est pareil on on
travaille en équipe voilà c'est c'est il
faut une une solidarité dans une équipe
pour que ça marche bien aussi c'est ce
qui similaire avec le rugby David
Douillet lui s'est mis à la chasse sur
le tard à 40 ans il s'est découvert une
seconde passion l'image de la chasse
c'est pas du tout celle que l'on a
habituellement des espèces de types qui
tir sur n'importe quoi et viandard c'est
pas du tout ça en tout cas la chasse que
nousous
c'est celle qui est la plus respectueuse
de la nature et qui la protège merci
beaucoup merci vous avez coupé et
maintenant vous pouvez filmer David
douill parce qu'il est dans les
meilleurs au niveau de la danse là-bas
venez filmer le J déclare premier de ce
groupe
c'esti et peut-être même une trè passion
grâce au danseurs burkinabé David douill
judoka chasseur et champion de danse
africaineé ch avec David c'est donc lui
qui a remporté le concours c'est ça
alors c'est David qui a remporté le
concours au au bout de plusieurs
épreuves parce qu'on a commencé le matin
par du tir avec une carabine linéaire
qui est LAX donc on a on a fait plein de
choses l'arrappe le sillet courant la
tour le rabbit beaucoup de choses et
c'est David qui remporte le con courours
c'est un excellent tireur mais c'est un
compétiteur he de toute façon on peut
pas lui enlever ça il est pas arrivé à
ce niveaulà par hasard mais tous les
gens qui sont dans mon association ce
sont tous des compétiteurs donc il y a
eu une belle ambiance hier mais il y a
eu vraiment esprit de compétition
c'était ils étaient pas là pour rigoler
quoi malgré Didier vous vous êtes mis à
la chasse petit gibier et puis vous êtes
passé au gros gibier récemment c'est ça
oui je suis passé au au gros gibier ces
deux dernières années parce que bon il
s'avère que chez nous le sanglier
notamment et et et je dirais très
présent c'est le le département où il se
prélève le plus de sangliers en France
27500 sangliers dans la saison dans la
dans le département du gare donc
forcément et bien je m suis mis parce
que je suis passionné par la chasse donc
autant par le petit gibier que le gros
gibier et donc je je m'y retrouve et et
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une une
une belle chasse je suis sûr que ça va
vous intéresser je vous propose du sport
du la chasse à l'arc ça reste du sport
et en quelque sorte c'est une pratique
qui était assez confidentielle mais qui
se développe ces dernières années
reportage berenis du failli améie
godonzo avec mea Mendy si Eddie passe un
harnais ce n'est pas pour s'adonner à
l'escalade quoique le chasseur préfère
guetter son gibier en hauteur pour être
sûr de ne pas le rater une originalité
et ce n'est pas la seule puisque l'homme
n'utilise pas un fusil mais un arc dans
ce type de chasse il faut être très
précis viser les zones vitales de
l'animal et surtout être silencieux pour
s'en approcher au plus près car il est
interdit de tirer à plus de 15 m de sa
proie avec quel gibier je tire là on a
qu'une flèche on en a pas deux on n pas
de coup à répétition on a qu'une flèche
et elle doit être mortelle donc on n'a
pas d'autre solution que de s'entraîner
et d'être d'être d'être aguéri quoi la
chasse à l'arc a longtemps été assimilée
à du braconnage ce n'est qu'en 1995 que
cette pratique est légalisée tous les
chasseurs détenteurs d'un permis peuvent
la pratiquer à condition d'avoir aussi
suivi une formation spécifique la
discipline séduit surtout les chasseurs
de longue date en quête de sensations
nouvelles et de difficultés des
chasseurs comme
Xavier je pratique aussi d'autres modes
de chasse ça ne m'apporte pas la même
chose on chasse aussi avec des chiens à
côté les les larc ça apportent une
proximité avec le gibier on voit des
choses on prend le temps de voir des
choses qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs donc
les les c'est l'intérêt de la chose en
France sur un million de chasseurs seul
20000 tirent à l'arc mais ce chiffre
augmente chaque année dans le Loir et
par exemple ils sont environ 800 à avoir
échangé leurs balles contre des flèches
ah c'était sympa hein ouais très bien
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous je
suis ravi de vous avoir rencontré reste
avec nous euh on va retrouver notre
électron libre Denis de l'autre côté du
château il est façade sud et quelque
chose que ça me dit que et quelque chose
me dit que on me dit qu'il est pas
encore ah ben il est prêt finalement bon
très bien quelque chose me dit que ça va
être un un show pour cette fin
d'émission Denis non mais ben oui bien
sûr là c'est un petit peu difficile de
traverser le le le le village he ce qui
est normal il y a il y a beaucoup de
monde mais on est là on va les voir
alors vous savez le Frisbey vous
connaissez le frisbe et bien on va aller
voir comment ça se passe avec un frisbe
pour passer des bons moments avec son
chien bah oui parce que ce salon c'est
pas forcément que la chasse c'est aussi
et bien le la la nature l'environnement
c'est aussi les loisirs alors je vais
tout de suite aller voir Yannick Yannick
Yannick Yannick comment ça va ça va bien
on est en direct Yannick c'est une
spécialiste c'est une spécialiste alors
je disais que c'est à la fois du du du
Frisbey du freestyle qu'est-ce qu'on
c'est quoi ce sport bien étrange alors
en fait il y a deux disciplines il y a
une distance une discipline qui
s'appelle la distance ou le TOS and
fetch qui consiste c'est un peu comme on
joue au frisbe sur la plage en fait on
lance le frisbe à son chien le chien
ramène le frisbe tout simplement et puis
on a une discipline qui s'appelle le
freestyle qui est là une véritable
chorégraphie en musique qui dure 2 2
minutes et voilà c'est vraiment étudié
c'est en fonction de la musique c'est
vraiment sympathique c'est vraiment des
acrobaties avec le chien en fait allez
très bien merci je sais que vous avez
été championne l'année dernière voilà
même avec Yeti il est où Yeti alors Yeti
est là elle sera pas championne cette
année parce qu'elle a un petit peu mal
au dos et je suis obligée de déclarer
forfait d'cord mais elle a fait une très
belle manche ce matin donc j'étais
contente quand même voilà merci on va
aller on va aller maintenant voir notre
ami qui est là qui s'appelle David
bonjour David alors lui il est champion
d'Europe 2011 s'il vous plaît alors on
va faire un un test avec votre chien r
voilà alors vous allez voir c'est un
grand moment de télévision alors je vais
lancer le Frisbey hein je lance par là
le frisbe oui oui par là oh mon petit r
attention attention hop je lance le
frisbe et vous allez voir asse
extraordinaire hop là je
lance voilà il va le récupérer ah il y a
des gens qui applaudissent c'est bien
alors voilà mon petit r on va le refaire
vous allez voir c'est extrêmement facile
on pourrait pas un autre endroit un peu
plus tiens par là parce que je vais
mettre Charlie tiens viens de l'autre
côté viens voir viens voir j'ai
t'expliqué pourquoi on va voir hop on
lance allez
attention et là je m j'en prends un
autre j'en prends un et je lui
monte extraordinaire non c'est
formidable extraordinaire magnifique je
vais avoir du mal à me relever parce que
c'est pas facile quand même à mon âge si
vous savez pas quoi faire après France 3
vous pourrez vous recycler ah B là je
pense que je vais devenir éducateur
canard ou clown artiste
clown merci merci mon petit r merci
merci à vous tenez vous le voyez cette
émission spéciale
de TR de la révec sy bonjour Sylvain
bonjour vous allez bien très bien
toujours vous êtes très sollicité sur
Game tout le monde vous veut un petit
peu oui oui on anime donc durant tout le
weekend le gamfire avec donc notre
association les plaisirs de la trompe
qui nous permet aujourd'hui de regrouper
tous nos amis pour pvoir animer bel
événement merci beaucoup sy on va vous
écouter juste le temps pour moi Mercier
toutes les équipes techniques de
Normandie de France 3 Normandie
éditorial merci à améli rigodonzo
pierredominique leopé Charlie CRIF
Sébastien nessan Christal chapiotin et
Ivan avril on va scuter donc en musique
avec les honneurs euh sur France 300
c'était vous regardiez le 33e game fair
en direct de France 3 cent j'espère que
vous avez passé un bon moment Denis vous
êtes encore là oui oui oui je suis là un
merveilleux moment et regardez non ben
mais je mais j'apprends ce que roman est
en train de m'enseigner voz voir
regardez hop faites le venir sur vous
roman sur vous h la position
extraordinaire h regardez ça regardez
ça je en train d'apprendre allez le
chien allez allez ENF il m'écoute pas
moie c'est génial quelle belle image
allez merci beaucoup de on se quitte
donc en musique avec les sonurs de Tromp
de la région Centre allez-y je vous en
prie merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous
équipages